for many people the word mysticism
doesn't necessarily conjure associations
with
Christianity mysticism is often more so
connected to non-abrahamic Traditions
perhaps Hinduism or Buddhism different
forms of Western or non-western
esotericism or perhaps modern phenomena
such as crystals astral projection and
the so-called New Age movement but in
fact it is within Christianity that the
very term mysticism actually emerges and
so is kind of the least problematic
place to use this phrase uh you know we
often talk about how the word mysticism
can become an issue it can become
problematic in different ways when
applying it to uh Traditions like Islam
and Judaism for various reasons this is
not as true of Christianity since the
term basically developed as a way to
explain a particular aspect of
Christianity throughout history still
even within Christianity the word
mysticism is often thrown around by
different people which creates more
confusion than than anything else uh but
what actually is Christian mysticism
where does this term come from and what
is this vast and fasinating tradition
that the term is referring
[Applause]
to mysticism in Christianity is
obviously a very big topic to tackle
which includes and interacts with some
of the most major developments and
figures in Christian history from the
church fathers and monasticism to the
core Theology of the Eastern Orthodox
Churches the medieval figures like me
eot Hildegard meld of magdor even later
Protestant thinkers like yakob buma and
all the way until the Contemporary age
and its different
developments but before we get into all
of those particular subjects we need to
take a step back first what do we
actually mean when we say mysticism and
what kind of my mysticism counts as
Christian mysticism is a notoriously
difficult term to talk about and to
Define because everyone seems to have
slightly different parameters through
which they understand it when used today
mysticism is often construed as a kind
of overarching category there is such a
thing as mystical or mysticism that can
be applied to different Traditions or
religions there is Christian mysticism
Islamic mysticism Jewish mysticism Hindu
mysticism Etc and in all this despite
religious differences there seems to be
something that all these quote unquote
mysticisms have in common which makes
them precisely that
mysticism now I'm not saying that this
is actually true only that this is the
way that the word is often used and the
assumptions that many people have as a
result we often point to particular
aspects of all these different religions
that they have in common as being the
mysticism in question but what is this
quote unquote mysticism this is where
think get a little difficult in his
classic work the varieties of religious
experience William James defines
mysticism as pertaining in particular to
experience mysticism is defined as
individuals having mystical experiences
often involving an encounter with the
absolute and an absorption into the
absolute but to many today this appears
a bit too narrow surely when people talk
about mysticism they also refer to
specific expressions or ideas expressed
in accounts or written texts as well as
practices that relate to these
experiences and ideas if we accept this
idea of mysticism as a legitimate
category it seems that what all these
supposed mysticisms have in common are
ideas about Transcendence that we can
transcend our regular human
consciousness and encounter the absolute
or God that we can indeed somehow even
Unite with God this is often the peak
experience which mystical practice aims
to end uce and mystical theologies or
ideas try to theorize about but as
always all of these terms can become an
issue what do we mean by experience to
begin with is this the same as Visions
for instance or is it something else
furthermore many of the most prominent
quote unquote Mystics of the Christian
tradition such as M eot often reject
mystical experiences as totally useless
and what's more what is meant by Union
with God we see this concept and term
used by many Christian Mystics in
history but it can mean very different
things depending on who is talking in
light of all this the leading scholar of
Christian mysticism today Bernard mcin
suggests another definition or emphasis
for what mysticism entails in the
Christian context he says quote thus we
can say that the mystical element in
Christianity is that part of its belief
and practices that concerns the
preparation for the consciousness of and
the reaction to What can be described as
the immediate or direct presence of
God here he chooses the term
Consciousness rather than experience and
rather than talking about Union which
seems too narrow given the different
ways that it can be understood he
chooses the broader term of God's
presence as the unifying factor in
mysticism which I also feel is a rather
Wise Choice so that will be our working
definition for this episode which of
course opens up to an absolutely
enormous topic and subject nonetheless
which we can only cover very briefly or
or on a on a surface level in such a
short episode as this there's also the
important fact that mysticism although
not necessarily mystical as we'll see is
a relatively recent term especially the
way it is understood as a kind of
category of its own most quote unquote
Mystics would never have considered
themselves Mystics because that wasn't
even a category that could be identified
with mcin writes
no Mystics at least before the present
Century believed in or practiced
mysticism they believed in and practiced
Christianity or Judaism or Islam or
Hinduism that is religions that
contained mystical elements as part of a
wider historical Hall these elements
which involve both beliefs and practices
can be more or less important to the
wider body of believers they also can be
present in various degrees of intensity
and development when they reach a level
of fully explicit formulation and
Paramount importance for certain
adherence of the religion I would argue
that we can speak of mysticism proper
though even then mysticism is
inseparable from the larger whole so
just like when we talk about the sufis
or Sufism as not being distinct from
Islam so with Christian mysticism the
same is true that it has simply been an
aspect of the wider uh theology practice
and experience of
Christianity in any case if we Define
mysticism in the way that that we just
have where do we find such ideas in the
Christian tradition well basically right
from the beginning and arguably even
before that as we know Christianity
essentially grew out of Judaism and in
that earlier religion we already have
features that could be deemed mystical
many of the stories about the biblical
prophets and the revelations from God
take on a mystical character such as the
famous Chariot vision of Ezekiel or even
the character of the some of the Psalms
I would argue further the movement known
as apocalypticism which emerged from the
first few centuries BC featured dramatic
mystical visions and Indian works like
The Book of Enoch in other words even by
the time that Jesus himself is walking
around in the Galilee preaching to
fellow Jews he's inheriting a tradition
full of mystical expression in a way the
very figure of Jesus and his mission
according to Christianity is somewhat
mystical in nature God becomes present
to human beings directly through Jesus
God God literally walks the Earth as a
human being but it is after the death of
Jesus that the movement that would come
to be known as Christianity develops by
subsequent generations of followers and
as soon as we have writings by early
Christians we find traces of the
mysticism which we have talked about
Paul's Vision on the road to Damascus
can certainly be considered a kind of
mystical experience and with some of the
earliest Church fathers its Expressions
start to show up again this is perhaps
most clear and relatively controversial
figures like origin and Clement of
Alexandria whose philosophizing vision
of Christianity included colorful
descriptions and ideas about the
relationship between God and the world
but also in more widely accepted and
foundational figures of Christian
thought such as Gregory of Nissa and the
so-called capid doans here the topic of
neoplatonism becomes relevant as it
often does many of these early figures
of Christianity were obviously highly
familiar with and often took inspiration
from the philosophical thoughts and
ideas of the helenic peoples living
around them and at the time the
philosophical School of neoplatonism was
especially powerful and popular a school
you could say founded by the great
platinus who taught about the emanating
outflow of all things from the so-called
the one and the goal of subsequent
return from the world of Multiplicity
back to Union with this one furthermore
another key Heritage from neoplatonism
is its apophaticism
the idea that the absolute in this case
the one or later in later Expressions
perhaps God can never be grasped or
described in any way it is completely
Beyond human understanding or language I
have dedicated several episodes to
neoplatonism in particular already
including one that deals specifically
with neoplatonism and its relationship
with Christianity so if you want to know
about that topic more deeply you should
check out that video and because that
topic is so important for Christian
mysticism there will be some overlap
here between this video and that earlier
one it is often argued that in many ways
it is from neoplatonism and platinus
that much of the vocabulary or ways of
expressing mysticism actually comes the
apophatic theology the idea of emanation
and especially the theme of Union with
the absolute which we Define here
broadly as present um all comes from the
neoplatonist to a certain extent and
these themes are there in some of the
earliest Church fathers in particular
there's often talk in these early
writings about contemplation or theoria
in Greek U so contemplation of God such
as for example in the powerful
experience described by origin quote for
the eyes of the Mind are lifted up from
their preoccupation with Earthly things
and from their being filled with the
impression of material things and they
are so exalted that they peer beyond the
created order and arrive at the sheer
contemplation of God and at conversing
with him reverently and suitably as he
listens how would things so great fail
to profit those eyes that gaze at the
glory of the Lord with unveiled face and
that are being changed into his likeness
from glory to glory for then they
partake of some Divine and intelligible
Radiance the goal for the early church
fathers from these figures mentioned to
people like Augustine and others was
this sense of intimacy with God this is
sometimes expressed through the language
of Union with God in the early centuries
monasticism and aesthetical practices
became more more and more popular
especially as Christianity became more
accepted in the Roman Empire which meant
that people didn't really become Martyrs
anymore as a result of this there
appeared new ways of being a modder in a
symbolic sense by giving up one's body
and life entirely for God it is thus
with the desert fathers and mothers
often said to have originated with
Anthony the great that Christian
monasticism becomes a prominent thing as
well as other forms of aestheticism and
pronunciation in the Middle East and
Mediterranean region one would live a
life of celibacy fast practice
self-mortification of different sorts um
in the case of the desert fathers they
would go out and live alone in the
desert and caves in the desert or in
cloistered communities focusing entirely
on prayer and devotional practice this
development is very significant for
Christian mysticism with the desert
fathers and mothers something was
started people who would go out into the
Wilderness and live as Hermits
dedicating their whole lives to prayers
and self modifications of different
sorts including of course the harsh
climate
itself these extreme practices would
lead as they often do to intense
experiences of a mystical sort and even
though this aestheticism eventually
became less extreme with the
establishment of monasticism proper with
its rules and communal living it is in
these environments that quote unquote
mysticism would really
flourish it's worth pointing out that
for much of History most of the mystics
of Christian Christianity were connected
to monasticism in some way and the
ultimate achievement that was sought
from all these practices and which was
intellectually described by some of the
great Scholars was precisely this idea
of Union with God of being entirely
conscious of God's all-encompassing
presence the word that came to be used
for this state or goal was theosis which
literally means becoming Divine or
becoming God perhaps this is well
encapsulated in a famous saying a uted
to both athanasius and Gregory of naanis
that quote God became human so that we
might become God through the sacrifice
of Jesus on the cross God opened up the
possibility for humans to quote unquote
become God or at least to become Divine
in some way now this must be understood
in a more nuanced way Christianity is a
monotheistic religion where the
distinction between God and creation is
greatly emphasized when these figures
talk about the does of uniting with God
this isn't meant in the direct sense of
the human being becoming a God or deity
or that there is ever a complete
identity between the two although we do
find expressions of this more monistic
sort later on in history which we'll
see this Union is described in different
ways and seems to mean quite different
things depending on who is talking like
we said but generally it does mean some
sort of participation in the Divine Life
and a divinizing of the human being
and around the year 500 we get one of
the most significant written expressions
of mysticism in early Christianity with
the figure pseudo dionisius or dianus
the areopagite who basically coins the
term mystical in the sense that we use
it in his famous short trus Mystic
theologus or the mystical theology
dianus lays out this quote unquote
mystical theology as one of apophaticism
the idea that we cannot make any
positive statements about God that is
completely Beyond any description or the
grasp of human
Minds significantly dianus also talks
about God or the absolute as a total
darkness or nothingness a nothingness
that resides in the depths of human
consciousness we can know God only
through unknowing through stripping away
everything we know and everything we are
into the complete darkness and
nothingness at the core of our being and
only there can God be found this is just
like Moses who climbs Mount Si to speak
with God which dianus reads as a
metaphor for Moses actually climbing the
mountain of his own soul into increasing
unknowing and nothingness until quote
then the people stood at a distance
while Moses Drew near to the thick
Darkness where God was dianus explains
quote but then he Moses breaks free of
them away from what sees and is seen and
he plunges into the truly mysterious
darkness of Unknowing
here renouncing all that the Mind May
conceive wrapped entirely in the
intangible and the invisible he belongs
completely to him who is beyond
everything here being neither oneself
nor someone else one is supremely United
to the completely Unknown by an
inactivity of all knowledge and knows
beyond the Mind by knowing
nothing
[Music]
an important point to be made here is
that this isn't just some abstraction or
theoretical philosophizing about this
darkness of God and and and this
apophaticism it's also a kind of
practical instruction right this
apophaticism this mystical theology is
not just about thinking about God in
fact it's quite the opposite it's about
not thinking it's it's it's a kind of
it's a way of of of the soul to to reach
god
um you know many people today sometimes
actually want to make a distinction
between mystical theology on the one
hand which this would be an example of
and mysticism on the other hand but this
distinction this distinction is really
not very useful especially in this case
the late prominent Orthodox scholar
kalistos or Timothy we said quote in
fact many of those who use the apathetic
approach saw it not just as a
philosophical device for indicating
God's utter Transcendence but also and
much more fundamentally as a means of
attaining Union with him through
prayer all of these early developments
would become core aspects of mystical
Christianity for the rest of History the
ideas of fosis and especially the
expressions of someone like dianus
became especially prominent in the
so-called Eastern Orthodox church but
it's also become influential in Catholic
and Western Christianity too to many
Christians there was a way to reach an
intimacy with God to experience God's
presence or even to be United to God a
way that involved not looking for God
externally in the world but internally
by purifying the soul and traveling into
that apophatic Darkness at our core
where paradoxically the light of God can
be experienced as one translation of the
Gospel of Luke seems to indicate the
kingdom of God is within you or in the
saying of the aforementioned desert
Father Anthony the great who said that
quote he who knows himself knows God as
we all know over the centuries the
church would start to split apart due to
uh theological and Authority related um
differences uh which kind of reached it
its culmination in 1054 with the
so-called Great Schism all right when
Christianity was divided into the
Western Catholic church and the Eastern
Orthodox
church and while mysticism has played an
important role in both of these across
history it's often said that it played a
more prominent role in the at least in
the mainstream aspect of the Eastern
Orthodox Church more so than in the
western Catholic Church where things
like um scholasticism in the later
Middle Ages sort of made mysticism less
popular and while there is some truth to
this description and this this division
it's also a lot more complicated than
that in eastern Orthodoxy the dev key
practices like hesm a meditative
practice often involving the so-called
Jesus prayer and certain movements of
the body as a way to achieve mystical
experiences and the ideas of mystically
oriented theologians who defended hiasm
such as Gregory palamas became part of
the official Orthodox
theology the 20th Century theologian
Vladimir lki wrote quote the Eastern
tradition has never made a sharp
distinction between mysticism and
theology between personal experience of
the Divine mystery and the Dogma
affirmed by the church there is
therefore no Christian mysticism without
theology but above all there is no
theology without
mysticism in any case while such goals
and Ambitions were present from the
earliest periods of Christianity and
arguably even before that um over the
centuries they developed more particular
uh practices and ideas um that aim to to
induce these kinds of mystical um again
using that word but mystical experiences
and hesm is just one example of this it
is also in this period in the later
Middle Ages that we start to see some of
the most famous and profound examples of
mystical literature being written uh
which will become very significantly
famous for the rest of History both
written in you know Scholastic language
but also written in vernacular languages
as we said many of these developments
particularly in the Middle Ages and in
Western Christianity are connected with
monasticism and the Monas IC orders many
of these are of course still alive and
well today such as the benedictines the
cians and mendicant orders such as the
Dominicans and franciscans just like
these Sufi orders in Islam these
Christian orders are communities of men
and women that take a vow to be
initiated often involving living in
celibacy for example and following a
particular monastic rule associated with
that order or spiritual techniques and
practices associated with the founding
figures of a given community so the
franciscans follow the president of
Francis of AI and the Dominicans that of
St Dominic Etc Francis of AI is indeed
one of the most important figures in the
history of Christian mysticism who
instigated a new kind of mysticism that
wasn't completely cut off from the world
as earlier Hermits had been but rather
living aesthetically in the world and in
service of other people which would
become the norm for many orders going
forward these monastic communities or or
orders involved both men and women and
indeed women are especially important
for the history and development of
Christian mysticism in
particular some of the most famous and
influential Mystics were indeed women
whose reputation or writings have
cemented them in history some of them
were nuns thus part of organized
monastic order such as the German figure
hilard of bingan probably one of the
most fascinating figures of medieval
Europe she was a Benedictine and
polymath of the 12th century who left a
mark in many different fields she
founded monasteries herself brought
books of Theology and had incredibly
intense mystical Visions which he would
describe in colorful and breathtaking
ways in famous works like the skas but
on top of this she was also a composer
who wrote religious pieces of music that
still survive and is played today she
was an artist who painted beautiful
pieces to try to visualize some of those
Visions she had as well as even
inventing a language of her own
Hildegard is an absolutely incredible
figure and one of the most significant
Christian Mystics in history but many of
the most famous women were not connected
to a monastic order per se but practiced
their Christianity in various different
ways in particular one of the most
significant developments from the 13th
century in northern Europe was the
emergence of the so-called beins and
beards in essence these were lay orders
not directly connected to the church the
beins who were the female side of it
would live together in communities
similar to nuns but they didn't take any
formal vows and could technically leave
and live a regular life any time they
wanted this relative Independence also
allowed the beins to express their
spirituality in unique and very
interesting ways from these be
communities we get some of the most
fascinating Christian Mystics such as me
of magdog hadish and maybe margarit
poret although the later's actual
connection to the begins is somewhat
uncertain the writings of these women
are important not only for being some of
the earliest examples of vernacular
mystical writings in Christian Europe
but also for the intimate and striking
ways that they describe the
consciousness of God's presence and
Union that they experienced one of the
most prominent themes or aspects here
and again there are parallels with the
episode on Sufism is of course
love when you read these Mystics
especially those often referred to as
effective Mystics you will quick realize
how the language of love and longing is
one of the key ways that they talk about
the relationship with
God in the begin writers like mild and
hadish this is very apparent and it even
takes on outright erotic imagery a lot
of the time taking inspiration from
courtly love literature they describe
their relationship with God as one of
lover and beloved God being portrayed as
a man whose Embrace they desperately
long for and the ultimate wish to reach
that ecstatic Union in the bridal
chamber which as you can see is
sometimes portrayed symbolically as a
sexual act just listen to how hadish
describes this love quote we see his
mouth brought close to us to kiss him
who wishes it his arms are outstretched
the one who wishes to be embraced May
throw oneself into them yes to put it
briefly God has inclined himself toward
us in time in all we can have and wish
to have from him and all we can
understand as much as we wish and
according to as we wish in order that he
may be with us in love and in
fruition moreover metil describes in her
famous work the flowing light of the
godhead a deeply erotic description of
the mystical Union quote the Bride of
all Delights goes to the fairest of
lovers in the secret Chamber Of The
Invisible godhead there she finds the
bed and the Abode of Love prepared by
God in a manner beyond what is human our
Lord speaks stay Lady
Soul what do you bid me Lord take off
off your clothes Lady Soul you are so
utterly fored to my nature that not the
slightest thing can be between you and
me then a blessed Stillness that both
desire comes over them he surrenders
himself to her and she surrenders
himself to him what happens to her then
she knows and that is fine with me love
is the primary drive that leads you to
God and His presence and here Hide some
profound and significant metaphysical
and epistemological corner stones of
Christian mysticism and in many ways
mysticism in general while Mystics don't
necessarily neglect reason and
philosophy per se inherent in mysticism
is often a clear demarcation of the
limits of human reason we can know
certain things about the created world
through reason sure but when it comes to
God things are
different we might be able to reason
that God exists and that he is
transcendent Etc But ultimately God is
so Transcendent in fact that human
reason is entirely incapable of knowing
him fully in other words mysticism will
often present alternate ways of knowing
that has to take over once we cross over
that boundary Beyond which reason can
never Venture this is that other kind of
knowledge or Insight that isn't reached
by reason but by other mystical means we
saw a similar Concept in Sufism with the
idea of mif and v as a kind of mystical
unveiling or tasting as opposed to
reasoned conceptual knowledge and we
find very similar ideas in the Christian
Mystics as well indeed just like the
sufis Christian Mystics will use the
term and concept of love as a signifier
for this Metar rational knowledge it is
only through love that we can truly
reach and know God and in the be Mystics
this takes on pretty radical expressions
the love that is felt for God is painful
the longing throws the person into
Despair and it is in them that loving
suffering that the goal is reached
mirroring the suffering of Jesus on the
cross the mystics suffer for their love
of God as that love becomes so strong
that it completely annihilates the self
of the person and then only God is left
they have in other words reached that
Union the UN mystica that we have talked
about me kind of Echoes M ehart when she
says quote no one is able or is
permitted to receive this greeting
unless one has gone beyond one self and
has become nothing in this greeting I
want to die
living and hardik speaks very plainly as
she exclaims quote I remained in passing
away in my beloved so that I wholly
melted away in him and nothing any
longer remain to me of
myself this theme of love as the impulse
that leads to God and its relationship
to reason becomes especially apparent in
the writings of the French Mystic
margarit
poret in her master Masterpiece the
mirror of simple Souls she essentially
presents a metaphorical dialogue between
different characters the soul which is
probably herself love and reason this
Dynamic is at the core of the book love
is clearly the source of ultimate wisdom
to margarit and represents her own views
and teachings it isn't philosophical
rational arguments but ineffable
mystical knowledge that is conveyed by
love in this book but margarit pet was
fully aware that what she was teaching
through this character of Love would be
controversial this is why the character
of reason is so important reason will
always jump in and criticize or question
the statements made by love obviously
representing not only reason and its
limitations in understanding the
realities of mystical love but also the
critics and Scholastics of the church at
the time and the conclusions that love
and thus margarit comes to in the book
are quite radical just like her German
contemporaries she essentially claims
that the soul can become fully
annihilated in God so that nothing of
the individual remains in particular
this is expressed through the will the
individual will disappears so that her
will is the will of God Only God and His
will remain and the two are one in that
sense quote reason says are you saying
that the soul has no will at all love
replies truly no for everything that she
Wills by her con desent is that which
God Wills that she would will and this
she Wills so that the will of God may be
accomplished not at all her own will and
she cannot will this of herself but it
is the will of God that wills it in her
and so it is clear that this Soul has no
will at all that she has to will the
conclusions of these ideas became very
controversial and actually led to
margarit being burned at the stake in
Paris in 1310 but the mirror of simple
Souls continued to be influential and
popular
often under false authorship later on in
history and might have influenced
thinkers like my
ekot so clearly these women and their
writings are very significant for the
history of mysticism but there were also
of course men who had a similar Outlook
even expressing themselves in a similar
language of love and Union One such
figure is the fascinating 12th century
figure Bernard of clairo who among other
things wrote a famous commentary on the
Song of Solomon as the biblical book
that exemplifies the Divine relationship
of love as well as being an important
monastic reformer and even being
involved in the very founding of the
night's Templar Bernard also talks about
the Mystic path as essentially one of
love we purify all our worldly desires
and passions so that only love of God
remains until we become so enveloped in
this love that we become identified with
love itself and Achieve that highest
State of Union Bernard is careful to
point out that this high highest state
is temporary and will only be fully
realized in the
afterlife he also seems to mean that it
is simply the will that becomes United
the individual will becomes the will of
God just like Margaret put it and not
that there is an annihilation of the
entire self in God as we seem to find
more clearly in writers like hadish or
Mech this is actually a good example to
show that problem that we raised in the
beginning that this idea of quote
unquote Union can mean very different
things and thus become a less use ful
term about a century before Bernard the
Eastern Church also saw one of its most
influential and Visionary Mystics in
Simeon the new
Theologian as we mentioned the Eastern
Church has often emphasized the Greek
term theosis or divinization as the
mystical goal and this divinization or
Union is experienced and expressed by
Simeon through his many intense visions
of
Light by turning inward in spiritual
contemplation just like pseudo dius and
others had had pointed to earlier he
would have direct experiences of God's
light in mystical Union quote at once I
perceived a Divine warmth then a small
Radiance that Shone forth then a Divine
breath from his words then a fire
kindled in my heart which caused
constant streams of tears to flow after
that a fine beam went through my mind
more quickly than lightning this is what
a lot of simeon's Visions looked like an
experience of an Allen compassing
immaterial light that envelops the
person to where nothing else is seen or
experienced Jesus is the light of the
world the same light of God that was
seen by the disciples on Mount Tabor
that light at least potentially is
present within each and every one of us
and can be reached by contemplating
ourselves and to use the paradoxical
language of dianus diving into the
darkness and nothingness where that
light can be
found quote if he is light therefore but
we say that those who are clothed with
him do not perceive him in what respect
do we differ from a corpse if he is the
vine and we are the branches unless we
clearly show our Union with him we are
soulless wood fruitless and withered
matter which is fit for the unquenchable
fire clearly as we can see these Mystics
reach these experiences through rigorous
practice and ways of living and while
the Western Catholic Church developed
its many monastic orders this was not
really the case in the east the Eastern
Orthodox church does not have such
orders although monasticism itself is
still very prominent although there have
been monasteries and communities that
have been very significant throughout
history such as um St Catherine
Monastery in the Sinai desert in Egypt
which has stood for a very long time
since Antiquity and uh Mount AOS in
Greece for example which is basically an
island entirely made up of monasteries
and monks and where a lot of very
important developments took place um
particularly when it comes to Eastern or
Orthodox mysticism especially that
tradition known as hzm which we have
mentioned before the word hzm comes from
the Greek term hesia which means
something like inner Stillness or
meanings related to things like Solitude
and like we said these were practices or
techniques of prayer that we can broadly
call meditative repetitive recitals of
the Jesus prayer for long periods
accompanied by certain postures and
movements of the head and body as
already said the purpose of these
contemplative practices was to turn
inward to purify the soul of all
external things and to make that journey
into the apophatic darkness beyond all
understanding where again paradoxically
the light of God is
experienced God is not reached out there
in the external world but rather by
turning to the inmost part of our own
being after all as the account in
Genesis says all human beings were
created in the image of God this means
that we all collectively have a Divine
part of ourselves which is accessible
Timothy we wrote quote each of us is a
living Theology and because we are God's
icon we can find God by looking within
our own heart by returning within
ourselves the hezek practitioners
claimed to reach theosis and Union with
God where they would experience or see
the light or even essence of God this
became quite controversial in the 14th
century with the so-called Hast
controversy which again I have covered
in a previous episode but in the western
church there were of course other
similar developments for example we see
in the 14th century the composition of
the fascinating mystical work called The
Cloud of Unknowing whose author is
fittingly unknown but would become very
influential the book is essentially a
how-to manual for mystical practice and
experience talking about how the Mystic
focuses on specific phrases es or words
until one reaches the kind of Stillness
or silence inside to the so-called cloud
of forgetting where we forget all about
the outside world in our body and
eventually when we go even further we
reach the titular Cloud of Unknowing
beyond all Concepts and ideas which of
course is connected to the apophatic
tradition associated with dianus and
others in The Cloud of Unknowing we find
many similarities with the Hast
tradition in the East but of course with
its own unique ways of looking at things
and with its own language and
particularities we have here so far
talked about experiences visions and
epistemologies so how one can know God
and reach this Union with God and how
these experiences have been expressed
poetically and metaphorically but
there's also often talk about the idea
or or concept of a kind of mystical
philosophy um in other words that there
is a kind of metaphysical Outlook that
is inherently mystical
and that both on an anthological and and
cosmological level explains all these
phenomena how is it that the light of
God is experienced by the Hast what is
the nature of the so-called Union with
God what indeed is the relationship
between God and creation at all many had
accused Mystics in Hast of being
pantheists of saying that God and
creation are identical but was this true
we already saw a kind of philosophy like
this with the pseudo dius and his
influence who himself named it a
so-called mystical theology but such
metaphysical speculation and
systematizations became more pronounced
and clear in the Middle Ages partly in
response to or as a part of the wider
movement of scholasticism that dominated
much of the church and the newly founded
so-called
universities and for this development
there are few figures as interesting and
famous in the Catholic West as the
German Mystic philosopher and theolog
olian Meister ekot a Dominican frier who
taught at the University of Paris and
had a rather High standing in the church
eot became famous for his daring
mystical ideas and his amazing and
engaging sermons in the vernacular
language of Middle High German at the
core of Art's philosophy is a conception
of God as the grun or ground the grun is
God in his utmost Essence Beyond even
the persons of the trinity in this we
find Echoes of the iCal Theology of
pseudo dianus especially as eart
describes the ground as nothingness or n
in German God in his ground is beyond
thingness he is nothing or literally no
thing it's a total Abyss or ABG grun in
German of no thingness even more
significantly what eart proposes as the
core of his mystical vision is the idea
that there is only one ground in other
words the ground of the Soul at its
deepest levels and the ground of God God
is one and the same ground without
distinction quote it is not because
either the soul is grounded in its
essential reality or God in his but
because they are both grounded in the
same ground in a fused identity that
eart and his followers found the
language of the ground so rich in
meaning our ultimate ground is God's
ground in other words as is the ground
of all of reality eart proposes that
ultimately God is the only thing that is
e it says quote here God's ground is my
ground and my ground is God's ground
indeed one of the most recurring themes
in eart is that he identifies the
essence of God with being itself or more
precisely indistinct being meaning that
he doesn't have being in the sense that
a creature or any thing has being or
existence he is pure being or existence
itself
indistinctly and because God is the sole
possessor of this attribute this means
that when it comes to created things
they are absolutely nothing in
themselves any being or existence that
you or I have is really God's being and
that's identical to God himself at least
in so far as it is being there is a
certain distinction between created
things who are truly nothing and God who
is being itself but this also has the
implication that God is all there is and
thus presents what we could call a
certain kind of non
dualism eard says in a sermon that quote
if my life is God's being then God's
existence must be my existence and God's
isness is my isness neither less nor
more the world is both God and not God
both complete nothingness and at the
same time fundamentally participates in
the absolute indistinct being of God as
the ground of reality and he expresses
this perhaps most profoundly in one of
his most famous lines in which he says
quote the eye with which I see God is
the same eye with which God sees me on a
theological level eart builds his system
in really interesting ways to put into
words the paradoxical statements about
the ground and the world that we find in
his sermons and this system of his is
decidedly neoplatonic in nature with the
focus on uzgun and ingun going out and
going back in other words everything is
always flowing out from the ground and
returning back to it he describes God as
being in a process of bito a kind of
inner boiling which creates the
and which then eventually boils over
eulito to create the rest of the world
and it is in the ingun or return that we
find the keys to the mystical path that
he proposes just like so many of his
fellow Mystics eart emphasizes that we
are to penetrate back into God to detach
from the world of particularities and
individualism and return back to our
source eventually the further we reach
on this journey even God himself unbe
becomes as quote the Mystic is not
content to return to the God who acts
but affects a breaking through to the
silent unmoving
godhead if we can completely detach from
the created world and return inward to
our inmost ground where there is no
distinction between my ground and God's
ground that is how Union is achieved
quote you should completely sink away
from your Unice and flow into his his
and your you and his his shall become
one hour so totally that with him you
eternally comprehend his Unbecoming
isness and his unnamed
nothingness this is a cutting off of all
attachments to the world including the
ego self and its Works in a sense it is
to annihilate ourselves until there is
nothing at all remaining to echart
Detachment means to empty ourselves of
creative things and return to the silent
desert of the Soul which is endless and
it's only in this absolute abyss and
emptiness of the soul that God God shows
himself you must know that to be empty
of all created things is to be full of
God and to be full of created things is
to be empty of God when one is detached
completely from the created world when
we have become nothing and realize the
unity of the ground quote Art's mystical
way will be an invitation to the soul to
give up the nothingness of its created
self in order to become the Divine
nothing that is also all things it's
interesting to point out here that eart
really wasn't interested in experiences
or visions at all this is a good example
to show that this idea of defining
mysticism as being essentially uh
concerned with these things with
experiences of God or Union with God and
these things uh because ekart you know
few people would deny the fact that eart
was a Mystic I'm sure most of us would
um to some degree at least call eart a
Mystic but he was actually quite
critical of mystical experiences seeing
them as essentially useless in a way
that's maybe some hyper herbally but he
definitely was critical of experiences U
and did not see this kind of experience
as being the goal of of the mystical
path of Detachment in any stretch of the
imagination this was not what eart was
after even though you know
experiences maybe could give you a
glimpse into to the reality of God and
the ground uh it was not the goal of the
path whatsoever what eart sees as the
full achievement of the Mystic is not
some Vision or grand experience as such
but quote new ways of knowing and loving
based on states of awareness in which
God becomes present in our inner acts
Master eot is one of the most profound
mystical thinkers in history but he was
also quite controversial some of his
statements even being considered
heretical but regardless he would have a
lasting influence on later thinkers in
the Christian West from his more
immediate admirers and and students like
Henry suso and Johannes Toler to later
figures like Nicholas of kuuza and even
remaining an influence to many in the
modern world
in the Eastern Orthodox Church a
contemporary and similarly systemizing
figure is of course the great Gregory
palamas he was a monk at the famous
monastery at Mount AOS who became a
deciding factor in the aforementioned
hessy cast controversy for some context
some Scholars had raised concerns over
the Hast form of prayer particularly the
claim by its practitioners that they
would uh witness God or the light of God
um to experience God in some way at the
heights of their Unity visions
God himself can never be witnessed they
argued and many of the statements made
by the Hast about unity and God's
presence seem to be dangerously close to
pantheism this is where Gregory palamas
comes in as the greatest defender of
hesm and its mysticism in treatises like
the Triads for the defense of those who
practice sacred quietude known usually
as the Triads he formulated a
distinction between God's Essence on the
one hand and his energies on the other
being being a good apophatic Christian
Theologian he totally and unequivocally
considers the essence of God in other
words God in his true absolute reality
as totally beyond all comprehension or
experience quote God is not a nature for
he is above all nature he is not a being
for he is above all beings no single
thing of all that is created has or ever
will have even the slightest communion
with the Supreme nature or nearness to
it however when it comes to God's
energies the situation is different the
energies of God are the relationship of
God to the created World they are the
ways that God you could say manifest
himself in creation and through
experience now this is a very complex
theological doctrine of course that
requires a lot of study to fully grasp
but God's energies are not created
things they are uncreated and are in
some way fully God himself but in the
way that he communicates himself to
humans and to the world generally it is
these energies of God that are perceived
quote to say that the divine nature is
communicable not in itself but through
its energy is to remain within the
bounds of right
devotion God in his Essence is
completely beyond all creation he
transcends it completely and cannot be
experienced or conceived of but in his
energies God is present everywhere his
energy pering all of the created World
quote all creation is a gigantic burn
Bush permeated but not consumed by the
ineffable and wondrous fire of God's
energies unlike eart who was
controversial in the Catholic Church the
doctrines of palamas basically became an
official part of Orthodox Doctrine in
the East and remain so until today he is
thus one of the most significant
theologians and Mystics in Christian
history needless to say from The 14th
Century forward mysticism continue to
develop and appear in different places
and guises there are so many figures
that there just isn't enough time to go
through properly in an episode like this
from John of the Cross and his famous
Dark Night of the Soul Tera of Avila and
her important role in The Counter
Reformation in Spain uh the English
Mystic Julian of Norwich and her
ecstatic descriptions of unity with God
uh there is Nicholas of kuuza who
expresses a unique yet kind of echaran
neoplatonism in works like unlearned
ignorance and where he drops bombs like
quotes oh Lord when you look upon me
with an eye of graciousness what is your
seeing other than your being seen by me
in seeing me you who are deos abicus the
hidden God give yourself to be seen by
me no one can see you except in so far
as you grant that you be seen to see you
is not other than that you see the one
who sees you kuza talks about God as the
not other which leads him to give us
gems of literary Clarity such as quote
not other is not other nor is it other
than any other nor is it an other in
another for no other reason than that it
is not other which can in no way be
other as if something were lacking to it
as to an other for an other which is
other than something lacks that than
which it is other but not other because
it is not other than anything does not
lack anything nor can anything be
outside
it anyway like I said there are so many
gems of mysticism in both the Catholic
and and Orthodox churches that are so
fasting and important for the history of
the topic that we're discussing and
which we can maybe hopefully focus on
more individually in dedicated later
episodes but another topic that of
course should be brought up when we talk
about the history of Christianity and
the history of of mysticism Christianity
is of course the Protestant Reformation
what did this development mean for
Christian mysticism in general many will
say that there is no such thing as
Protestant mysticism that the
Reformation of people like Martin Luther
completely did away with this aspect of
Catholicism but this is of course a bit
of an overe exaggeration to be sure
mysticism was significantly altered and
changed as a result of the Reformation
but to say that it completely
disappeared that or that there is no
mysticism at all in protestantism is not
very true in fact mystical writers
influenced the early reformist
themselves in some ways Martin Luther
read The Works of Johannes Toler for
instance although he would significantly
disagree with many of his ideas but what
happens with the Protestant Reformation
is an abolishment of many features of
Catholicism as it had stood for
centuries before that point the
Protestants for instance abolished
monasticism in a general sense in other
words no more monks and nuns and as
we've seen it was in these monastic
environments that mysticism really had
their Center points for most of History
Luther's focus on faith as the only
salvific factor for humans rendered all
aesthetic practices and even so-called
experiences kind of useless in a sense
but we shouldn't take this too far
either remember how we Define mysticism
the preparation for consciousness of and
the response to the presence of God
certainly within protestantism we find
several figures who have claimed to
experience the presence of God in some
way just look at Pentecostalism and its
emphasis on the Holy Spirit entering the
person and phenomena like speaking in
tongues all of this could certainly be
defined as a kind of mysticism
especially with our working definition
today what did change significantly with
protestantism and of of course mysticism
had to change in the face of such
significant theological and
organizational differences was their
attitude to the central concept of Union
With God all these claims that Mystics
throughout the centuries had made about
being united with God or the Dian and
echaran claims that God is somehow
present in the depths of the human self
and can be discovered there these are
the things that were rejected by the
reformers completely this is interesting
because this means that if we Define
mysticism simply as the relationship to
Union with God as many often do then
protestantism certainly seems rather
anti- mystical but as we know things are
more complicated than that the history
of protestant Christianity is full of
all kinds of Mystics from imanos deori
to yakob BMA and even certain aspects of
the Quaker movements and other modern
denominations as we saw can certainly
have Tendencies and aspects that are
mystical in nature the situation today
is quite complex the topic of Christian
mysticism has become a topic of interest
and inspiration for people in Europe and
and America as an alternative to what is
perceived as a more dry form of
Christianity that many experience
growing up at the same time it has never
stopped being being a prominent feature
of the religion there are still
monasteries that function in Europe and
the Eastern Orthodox church has always
upheld a strong connection to mysticism
and its Theology and practice as we can
see it isn't something to be only
associated with new age movements and
modern popular religion but has been a
core aspect of Christian Orthodoxy for
much of History a serious and often
painful way of somehow reaching intimacy
with God or being conscious of his
presence however that presence is
interpreted in a theological sense from
Gregory of Nissa and pseudo dianus to
eart and the beins margarit pet and John
of the cross the Christian Mystics
continue to be a source of Fascination
and inspiration to both practitioners
academics and regular people alike and
they can just like their peers from
other religious Traditions show just how
varied and colorful religions can
actually be as always I want to thank
all my patrons over on patreon for
keeping this channel alive none of this
would be possible without you um I would
of course highly appreciate if anyone
else wanted to become a patron too so I
will leave links to that in the
description um and you can check it out
if you want to uh but of course also
thank you everyone to uh or for just
watching the the videos for subscribing
for for liking and engaging in the
comment section um I really appreciate
all of you and I am as I I always say
I'm I'm honored to be able to do this
work uh so thank you all so so much I'll
see you next time
[Music]